>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: Good
evening, and welcome.
I'm Anne McLean from the
library's music division.
We are delighted tonight
to have a rare opportunity
to present the distinguished
Shigeyama Kyogen Troupe,
masters of one of the world's
great comic theater traditions.
And artform more than
six centuries old.
We're so pleased tonight to
have with us Ippei Shigeyama,
an artist who represents
the 15th generation
of his illustrious family, whose
history is an indelible part
of Japan's cultural legacy,
welcome Ippei Shigeyama.
We're so glad that Washington's
beautiful cherry blossoms are just
about to burst into bloom
after that little storm.
It's perfect [laughter].
It's perfect.
So, just a quick question
I know of course you
and your family have appeared
in many international venues,
but is this your first
time in Washington?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
MATOKA SHAMUTZU: I passed
through once [laughter].
>> ANNE MCLEAN: So, we are
very, very pleased to have you
and it's very, very rare.
Our colleague Mari Nakahara
is from the Library's Prints
and Photographs Division and she has
been the master producer for a host
of wonderful events
here that are part
of the National Cherry Blossom
Festival, have been a part
over the past five years.
And let me also introduce Matoka
Shamutzu [assumed spelling]
for appearing as our
translator this evening.
Let me thank a number of people
for helping to make this possible.
The Library's co-presenting
this performance
with the Japan Information and
Culture Center Embassy of Japan
and the Japan Foundation.
And we're also pleased to be
collaborating with the Freer
and Sackler Galleries of the
Smithsonian's Museums of Asian art.
So, we'd like to thank Yokasi Kinowa
[assumed spelling] from the Office
of the Japanese Embassy, and
Kochi Nozaki [assumed spelling],
and Konoko Sheer Azakie [assumed
spelling] from the Japan Foundation,
they have been invaluable
colleagues.
Also, our colleague Michael
Wilpers from the Freer,
which will be offering a Kyogen
in two days at the Freer Gallery.
And thanks to also very much to
Dr. Dongfang Shao, who is the chief
of the Library's Asian Division and
to Aichi Eto [assumed spelling].
Tonight, when you leave
this you will have a chance
to see three beautiful rare books
that are on display in our foyer
which Aichi has chosen and
put out, plus some flutes
from the music division and this
will definitely illustrate the long,
long history of the
Shigeyama family.
So, now I'd like to turn
this over to Mari Nakahara.
>> MARI NAKAHARA: Thank you
Anne, and hello everybody.
My name is Mari Nakahara.
I am the curator for architecture,
design and engineering at the Prints
and Photographs Division.
I'm here today to talk about
the Library's participation
in the National Cherry
Blossom Festival.
The Library holds over 162 million
items covering an almost universal
range of the subject in diverse
formats, including resources,
related to cherry blossoms
and their history.
Right after I was hired as a
Japanese reference librarian
at the Library's Asian Division in
2007, I found these restorations
of 11 varieties of the cherry
blossoms, which were given
from the City of Tokyo to
Washington, DC in 1912.
I was so excited to see
these and I begin to dream
of making them known more broadly.
The more I found that I
explored the Library's collection
and the more I found
holdings related
to the cherry blossoms
in the 1912 gift.
Long story short, I, along
with my colleague Cathleen Brudd
[assumed spelling] also P&P,
mounted the Sakura, Cherry Blossoms
as Living Symbols Friendship
exhibition for an occasion
of the 100th anniversary of
the cherry blossom tree gift.
Multiple programs were held,
along with the exhibition,
including gallery talks,
lectures, K-12 programs and so on.
The exhibition and its gallery talk.
And also, many educational materials
are still available via the
Library website.
Oh, did I show you the?
I show you the drawings?
Did you see the drawings?
Oh, okay. All right.
So, if you go the website
you can still see point says
at the top learn more, or public
program and the exhibition items.
So, you can see everything.
Pursuing one of the Library's goals
of providing general understanding
of American culture,
intellectual and social life,
and of other peoples and nations.
I decided to continue to host
events in the program related
to cherry blossoms, coinciding
with the National Cherry Blossom
Festival every spring even
through the scale is much smaller.
One of the big event is
called Japanese Culture Day.
This program, presented by
the Library's Asian Division,
and also the Center for the Book,
introduced children and adult
to the Japanese culture through
hand-on origami artwork creation,
trying on Kimono and
other activities
as you are seeing on the web.
By participating in these
activities, people not only enjoy,
but also have an opportunity to
learn the meaning of each activity
from the library staff member and
the volunteers who have a depth
of knowledge of Japanese culture.
Additionally, Japan America Society
of Washington DC present
Japan in a Suitcase.
A program about Japanese
children's life and the culture.
We, each year, also provide
special presentations
such as children's book readings
and introduction of Japanese food.
This year, Siochi Takamori
[assumed spelling]
of DC Yamaguchi Karate Club,
will demonstrate karate.
Children will find
additional supplies,
which I must keep confidential until
the day of the event [laughter].
Last, but not least,
Cherry Blossom princesses
from the last few years instruct the
children in the art of tiara making.
Children also will
have the opportunities
to explore young readers centers
current and classic books.
The other program is a presentation
by professionals who have a depth
of knowledge of cherry blossoms
and the US Japan friendship.
I have invited speakers from
the National Parks Service
and book authors.
This year, three Washington,
DC area authors, Ann McClellan,
she is there, right there.
Stephen Voss.
And Sandra Moor.
Will share their bonsai experience
in an [inaudible] panel
presentation.
This panel discussion, presented
by the library's Asian Division
and Prints and Photograph's
Division, is an opportunity to learn
about the 53 bonsai trees, which
Japan gave as a bicentennial gift
to the United States in 1976.
The trees led to the founding
of the national bonsai
and the Penjing Museum US
National Arboretum [inaudible],
which was alter augmented
by bonsai from China,
North America and elsewhere.
The panel aims to expand the
public's knowledge, awareness,
and understanding of these
enchanting miniature trees
that are living works of art.
They also will discuss how
the national collection
of the bonsai inspired their books.
Ann McClellan in "Bonsai and
Penjing, Abassadors of Peace
and in Beauty" provides
the comprehensive overview
of the national operation.
Voss is the author of "In Training"
which features insightful
photography.
Moor, in the children's
book, "The Peach Trees
from Hiroshima" tells the story
of Yamaki Pine [assumed spelling]
a bonsai in training since 1625.
This year's Japanese Culture
Day will be held on Saturday,
this coming Saturday, March
25th between 10 a.m. and 3 p.m.
at the Library's Young
Reader's Center,
in Thomas Jefferson Building,
the same building where you are.
Japan in a Suitcase will
be presented at 11 a.m.
and at 1:30 p.m. followed by Karate
demonstration and a big surprise.
The panel discussion on bonsai gift
will be held on Tuesday April 11
at the Library's west dining
room, located on the 6th floor
of the James Madison Building.
Will begin with a book
signing at 11:30 followed
by the presentation at noon.
Both events are free
and open to the public.
Tickets are not needed.
You will hand this handout in the
program tonight, I look forward
to meeting with you at the event.
I would like to end my talk
by introducing the Edo prints,
which are held at library's
Prints and Photograph's Division
between 2005 and 2006,
the Nichibunken,
International Research
Center for Japanese Studies
in Japan contributed funding
support to digitize 1100
of the library's Edo prints and also
assembled the American Institutional
Team of the scholars from
Japan and the United States
to provide new cataloging
data for all
of the Edo prints at the library.
These images are available
through the library's Prints
and Photograph's Division online
catalog, which we call PPOC.
These include some examples of
prints which are related to Kyogen.
Please visit PPOC to explore
these and other treasures.
Thank you very much and today's
Kyogen talk and the presentation.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much and I hope
that you can come back
to some of these events.
This evening is the first time
that we've presented Kyogen
at the Library of Congress an
art designated by UNESCO as one
of the masterpieces of oral and
intangible heritage of humanity.
We once presented a
noh theater troupe
which was a memorable evening, and
I wanted to ask you Ippei Shigeyama
about the relationship of
Kyogen and noh theater.
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: Good evening.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, first off, that's
a big question,
relationship between noh and Kyogen.
Originally, they were
one in the same.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, we have noh and Kyogen and
these two drama forms coexist
within the single genre
of [foreign word].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, the way to enjoy it is to
see it alternately, first noh
and then a Kyogen interlude.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, noh is often, the
themes are rather tragic,
and it's structured
on a song and dance.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And, on the other hand, Kyogen
treats everyday subjects.
The characters are common people,
and it's about their comedic
situations of their everyday life.
So, in the past, people would spend
the entire day watching these plays.
So, it would be a repetition of noh,
then Kyogen, noh, and then Kyogen.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Of course, we have better things
to do these days [laughter].
So, normally you would go see
one noh play, or one Kyogen play.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, for a Kyogen play, typically
it's between 20 and 30 minutes.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, increasingly, as you are today,
people come to see
Kyogen plays only.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, I want to stress to you that
although we tend to think of Kyogen
and noh as separate things, I
want to stress that they used
to be part of, well, together.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: [Laughter] No, no,
we're Going to keep
going back and forth.
This is wonderful.
So, it's like a musical, in a
way it's like a counterpoint.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: Yes,
exactly like a counterpoint.
So, noh is very sober
and profound, very tense.
And then you would watch
the Kyogen for that release.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: You know, you were
saying that Kyogen is a theater
of gentle humor and everyday
satire and everyday situations
and I was reading that your
father, I believe made a comment
about how Kyogen is like tofu, and I
wondered if care to expound on that?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU:: So,
ironically it started as a slur
against the Shigeyama family.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, eventually the Kyogen became
patronized by the Samurai classes.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, in the Meiji Period when
the Samurai went out of power,
all the Kyogen performers
and noh performers lost
basically, lost their jobs.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, they attempted to survive
through the patronage and support
of people who were willing to do so.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But to mount a noh play you
need at least 20, 20 actors.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
On the other hand, a Kyogen play,
you only need five or six people.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, I think it made it, the
economic barriers were not
as high for Kyogen plays.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And also, they're shorter.
Which is sometimes preferred.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, from the Taisho Period, early
20th century to the Showa Period.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And even in Japan, women
were coming to power.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, often the Kyogen
plays functioned
as entertainment at
these girls' parties.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And also, for gatherings
for children.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And so, Kyogen was very well
adapted to these kind of places.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, in a sense, my grandfathers'
grandfathers were ancestors,
he tore, or plucked Kyogen
out of the larger picture
of [foreign word].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, then my ancestors they
would perform everywhere.
Weddings, temples, at parties.
And it became to be perceived that
Shigeyama Kyogen was everywhere.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, I'm not sure if this is
actually a Kyogen proverb,
but there's a saying if you're
lacking for a dish, have Tofu.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, Shigeyama Kyogen came to
be bad mouthed as tofu Kyogen
that it was everywhere,
common, but now, cheap.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But my ancestor said, well what's
wrong with tofu, tofu is fine.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, tofu is extremely versatile.
There's a tofu that your mom
would put on the dinner able,
or there's the tofu
that is presented
in a very refined way
in a restaurant.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, as long as there is tofu
for that that is appropriate
for that place, it should not
inconvenience anyone [laughter].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, if it's a very classy,
high-end event, it can be that
or if it's a kid's event
it can be that also.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so basically Shigeyama
Kyogen will never say no.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: Wonderful
[laughter].
We wanted to ask you a little
bit about the training of actors.
And I know it's very much a father
to son apprenticeship kind of thing
and I was wondering how
old most actors are.
How old were you when you began,
and when did you make
your first appearance?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: It
was at the age of four
that I first took the stage.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And I prepared for this
role for about six months.
That's what I hear [laughter].
I don't remember it.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: And, we were
thinking about too, how do you know?
It's a long apprenticeship I know
and we can talk about the study
of techniques, but how do you
know when you're finished?
Is there an official ceremonial
moment that you be begin
to make your debut as an adult?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: So, there's
a play called [foreign word].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, I've heard that once you
have role in [foreign word],
that means that you have become
a full-blown Kyogen actor.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
For me that happened
about 17 years ago.
But my father was very
critical about it.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, in my father's eyes, no doubt,
I'm still not yet a
full Kyogen actor.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: And
you'll have the chance
to see his father [inaudible]
tonight who is a very,
very distinguished actor
and we wanted to know too
about the hereditary title
that he carries and how does,
what is the nature of this?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: So,
the head of our family,
the name for that is
Shigeyama [foreign word].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, [inaudible] my father
who is here tonight,
he is the second [foreign word].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And [foreign word] was actually
my grandfather's birth name.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, after the Second World War.
So, in the world of entertainment,
there were many reforms
that were carried out.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, up until then, it was
absolutely Taboo or forbidden to mix
or intermingle with
different genres.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, you might come
out with a new work.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Or revive an old work.
And sometimes you would
have noh actors performing
in [inaudible] plays.
And that was absolutely unbelievable
by the standards of that time.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, my grandfather, because he
appeared in a [inaudible] play,
he was actually made to resign
from the Noh Association.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, when all this was happening,
my grandfather was still called
[inaudible] and not yet [inaudible].
At the time when all these
reforms were taking place.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, for us, the name is
associated with that very,
this period of great innovation.
And also, the Chinese
character [inaudible] is 753,
which is Japan is a very
auspicious and celebratory event
that celebrates the
health of children.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, we decided to keep
this as an actor name.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, the funny thing is we
decided we don't have to wait
until that person dies, it's okay
if there are two [foreign word].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
In Japan that's a little
bit unthinkable.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
It was very groundbreaking.
So, my grandfather's brother,
he said, well just step outside
of Japan and you see
that it's normal.
It's very normal.
Lots of people have the name of
their parents, or their fathers.
So, don't worry about it.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And that is how Shigeyama
became a family name.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: Speaking,
continuing the line of comments
about your father and so, on I know
that when you study the character's
their techniques [foreign word],
they are almost codified
and so on, but I understand
that a great actor
puts his own stamp
on these, makes his own version.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: So, take for
example my father or grandfather,
they will only teach us
about 70% of what they know.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, that part is what
has been transmitted.
But the remaining 30% is really
up to you to expand upon.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And that part, there's no way
they're going to give you that.
So, this is Something that you
have to watch and steal [laughter].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And this is ongoing.
And so, observing the acting of
other people, watching the stage,
that is an extremely
important part of our training.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: And I know
that you are really a star
in many ways in Japan.
You're in television,
the movies and so on,
and again very much
crossing boundaries
and expanding the horizons
of your generation,
I'm curious, do you have any?
Well, let's talk for a
moment about the Mozart Opera
that you talked about, yeah.
His family has been
involved with a number
of really exciting projects
involving many different things.
In Paris you're giving workshops,
residencies to teach techniques,
and they've been involved in
theater of the absurd like Beckett.
But there was a Mozart
opera collaboration
that I think you were involved in.
If you could talk a
little bit about that.
[Foreign word] was that it?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU:
So, in Japan less
and less people are
listening to classical music.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And people who go to
Kyogen theater, even less.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, in general, people who
go to these things are seen
as atypical, not normal [laughter].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, our thinking is that if you're
interested in classical music,
that is western classical music,
you might be interested
in Japanese classics.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And vice versa, if you're interested
in Japanese classics you
would no doubt be interested
in western classical music.
We thought it would be
easy for the audience
to understand what
we're attempting to do.
So, we had the idea that this might
be an audience that was receptive
and had a gentle attitude
towards classics.
And we thought it was a great
entryway, or gateway to this.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And that is how it started.
And I would call it
an opera style Kyogen.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: Interesting,
wonderful.
We're going to try to show a quick
clip, maybe you want to continue,
we'll try to turn this
on, if we can do this.
It's a very unusual,
let's see if we can.
>> Actually, I'm not sure how
to get out of your thing Mari.
Oh, you can?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, thank you.
And then we're going
to, oh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
We'll go to Chrome, and
then this one, thank you.
So, what this is a very, yeah,
it's a very unusual film made
by Yamamura, [inaudible]
Yamamura, in which.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
All acting parts are voiced
by, several of them are voiced
by his family, and he is in this.
[ Music ]
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU:
So, this is my cousin.
The voice you heard
before was my grandfather.
[ Music ]
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> ANNE MCLEAN: So, it's just to
give you a very quick sense of some
of the remarkable gestures
that their family has made.
And this might be a good spot
at which we could have one
of you ask a question I know
that we have to give time
for the actors to get ready.
Before we finish, let me just say
before I forget that we are able
to announce a very
extensive Utamaro exhibit
at the Arthur Sackler Gallery
for April 8th through July 9th,
and there's some brochures
about this,
and again we thank our
partners at the Freer Gallery
and the Sackler Museum as well.
So, thank you so much for
this time and do you wish
to take a question
or two, are you okay?
From the audience?
Okay. With the blue shirt there.
>> Hi thank you, I know
that [inaudible] has been
traditionally a male acting domain
is the same true for Kyogen?
>> Is it true for Kyogen?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: Well,
that was wishful thinking,
I almost say women only.
But yes, both noh and
Kyogen are limited to men.
>> Question over here.
>> I have attended a
number of Kyogen and noh
and [inaudible] performances
in Japan, in Italy,
and in the United States.
Six months ago, on September
16th, I saw a performance
at the Historic Teatro della
Pergola in Florence Italy
and it was sponsored by the
Embassy of Japan in Rome
and the Japanese consulate
in Florence
and they did just what
you described,
which is that there was
first an extensive noh play
and then two different
Kyogen theater productions.
Now, the Kyogen actors were
from the [foreign word] School
and actually I wrote down the
names, one was [foreign word]
and the other was[foreign word].
And my question was
this, if you are familiar
with this particular company,
would they have a different style
of presenting Kyogen
than your company?
In other words is there a
variety of different styles today
In the production of Kyogen theater?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: Of course,
I know both of them very well.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, Mr. Huto [assumed spelling]
he's much more advanced than I am
and [foreign word] is a bit younger.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And I actually belong to
the same [inaudible] school.
The scripts are almost identical.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But their activities tend to center,
in Tokyo, and we are Kyoto based.
So, we don't have that
much exchange day to day.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, of course, they're Tokyo
people so, they're, how do I say?
More stylish [laughter].
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, we're Kyoto so we
have a comedic touch.
>> I think I saw you in Kyoto at
a performance for a conference
in late August last
year, I'm not sure,
but I was wondering about the music.
Do you use the music
and how the music came
into being with the theater acting.
I believe it was, either
it Kyogen or noh, it was.
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: Are you
sure it was me [laughter]?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
End of August last year?
So, of course in Kyogen too
sometimes you have musical elements,
components.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
For example, when you have a
scene of [inaudible] drinking.
I think this is pretty
much universal,
so when you have a
drink, you start to sing.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, in that sense I
might have used music.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But that would be a sort of parody
of the chanting that occurs in noh.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, I think we might
have used some singing
that was similar to noh chanting.
>> So, I guess I'm
interested in the chanting.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: So, first of all
in noh chanting you don't
have music, a score.
So, you have a text and next to
the characters you have symbols.
And it's Jo up, down and middle.
So, the idea.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And this is very relative, it
almost depends on how you are
that day, your condition that day.
And it varies from individual.
So, it's not a fixed, it's
probably most accurate to say
that it's not a fixed thing.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: Wonderful.
Maybe one more and then
we'll have to move forward.
>> Hi, you've emphasized
revival of the works classics,
are there still being new works
produced today and written?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: So, the
way I see it, to revive things
that have sort of departed
from our contemporary mindset,
I think of that as
almost an obligation.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, even if the audience does
not quite get it, unfortunately,
it's up to us to know that.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, that is something we,
as people who are involved
in this traditional art
form, this is something
that we have to continue to do.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, of course when we
mount such performances,
mainly the [foreign word] the really
obsessive types will come out.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, in any case, we
only have 180 plays
which are considered the classics.
So, it's in a way it's
easy to see all of them
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But of course, we don't
put on all 180 plays.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And in most cases, we
try to select those
that have some contemporary
relevance.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So, performances that are
geared more toward a deep
research attitude.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But, we need to embrace
that also and continue.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: So, you are,
in fact I want to say too,
you create new plays
as well don't you?
At least I think so.
>> MATOKA SHAMUTZU: Yes.
>> ANNE MCLEAN: So, this
extraordinary family is,
from the time of Shakespeare,
playing and preserving the very old,
and remarkable, but also
creating the new, it's amazing.
So, we thank you for being
here and we are grateful.
We look forward to the performance.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.